Another neat thing about ES6 is
that you can extend the built-
ins. I don't mean monkeying with
the prototype of something like
an array or a number, but I mean
that we can create our own
classes that are modeled after
an array. Let's say we
wanted to create a movie
collection. I'm going to show
how we are going to use it first.
It's going to look like this.
We're going to say const movies
equals a new movie collection.
Now the movie collection is
going to take in Wes' Favorite
Movies -- that's the name of the
collection -- and then argument
two, three, four, five, and to
infinity, are going to be a
movie, where you have the name
of the movie and the number of
stars that you've given it.
What we need to do is, this is
kind of like an array except
it's going to have a property of
Wes' Favorite Movies, and then
we're also going to add methods
to this. What we do is we create
a new movie collection, then
we're going to extend the array.
That's the built-in one, right
there. Now, what do we need
here? We need a constructor.
What arguments are getting
passed in when we create a new
movie collection? The first
thing getting passed in is the
name of the collection, that's
easy. But then, how do we
capture items two, three, four,
five, to infinity? How do
you capture the rest of them?
Well, I just said it, you use a
rest. So, ...items. What that's
going to do is the first thing
is a movie and the rest of them
are going to be movies that get
passed in. The first of them is
a name and the rest of them that
get passed in are going to be
items. What we need to do
here is...we could try to do
this, this.name = name. That
gets passed in. Let's see how
that actually works. We get the
same error that we did in the
last one. This is not defined.
Why can't we set this on movie
collection? Because we have not
yet given ourselves that initial
array that we are extending it.
Remember, whenever you extend
something, you need to create
the thing that you're extending
first, before you create the
thing that you want. How do
we do that? We call super, and
this is just the same thing as
calling new array. A new array
will take item one, item two,
item three. How do we pass item
one, item two, item three? We
don't do items zero, items one...
We're not going to do that. That
will take forever and we don't
know how many there are. But we
can pass it in items. Let's take
a look at how that works.
We'll see our movies here, but
movies is an array of an array,
so now we have an array in an
array. That's not exactly what
we want. We want to be able to
put each item in there, so we
spread into the function because
items is an array, but we want
to pass super each item as an
argument. We spread into the
array. This is cool because
we've captured all of them with
a rest, and then we then turn
and spread them into our super
function, which is the array.
Let's take a look at it now.
There we go. Now we've got this
movies object, which if you open
it up, you see all of the
different movies that are inside
of it. We can also do something
like this, movies.name. Oh, Wes'
Favorite Movies. That's really
neat, that we can have an array
but we can also have properties.
That's because, at the end of
the day, arrays still are
objects in JavaScript. Now
what we can do is just add
methods to this movie collection,
like add. Let's say we wanted to
add a movie. That's going to say
just this.push(movie). Why?
Because, even though we have a
movie collection, we still have
inherited all of the array
methods. We'll be able to add a
secondary movie. Let's say
movies.add and we're going to
add a new movie here. The
name of that movie is going to
be Titanic, and the number of
stars is going to be five. I
should take a look here at
movies. The last movie is
Titanic. Movies.length. The
thing I want to show you is, if
I were to use the for...in loop
here, for const movie in movies,
and I were to console.log each
movie, watch what happens. We
get zero, one, two, three, four.
That makes sense because it's
the index, and then we get name.
Why do we get name? Because
movie has five items in it, but
then we also gave it a property
of name, and for...in will loop
over that. However, we also
learned about for...of, which
only iterates over the iterable
properties of an object. We can
use for const, just take this
const movie of. That's in, we'll
change it to of. Look at
that. We don't get name, and we
also get the actual object, not
just the key. That's a really
neat thing where you can still
add properties to an array, but
we're able to skip over those
properties with a for...of loop.
Let's add one more method to
this, where I want to be able to
sort this array of movies and
then get the top 2, 3, 10,
however many we want. We'll call
it top_rated(), which is a
method, and top_rated() is going
to take in a limit, in case you
want to limit how many movies
you are bringing back. If you
have thousands, you only want to
bring maybe the first 10 back,
so we'll set a default of 10.
That's using a default function
argument. Then all we have to do
is return this.sort. Why? What
is this? This is the actual
movie collection, which is an
array. Then we just say a, b,
then we'll say if the a.stars is
greater than the b.stars then
we'll have a -1 and 1. Then
what that does is it's just a
quick-and-dirty sort for us.
Then we can call .slice on it.
We'll start at zero, and go to
the limit. That will limit it by
default 10, or whatever we pass
in. Now we should be able to
call movies.top_rated and it
will bring back...Well, that's
not very good. Watch this little
trick. Console.table. That will
give us all of the movies,
sorted by the number of stars,
but I can also pass in like give
me the top two rated, and that
will bring me a table of the top
two rated. That's really
handy if you're able to have an
array, but also have methods on
front of it. Extending arrays,
you can extend any of the native
stuff that are built into
JavaScript to create your own
collections.